we are one out of two companies working
as a cisco select partner two years ago
we have been discussing with digicel the
the plan was to lunch for my money in
Haiti we had the idea to develop an
Android applications that would enable
the agent to capture all the information
beneficiaries we send them a message on
the telephone to tell them that you have
received money from undp to repair your
house and then the beneficiary goes to a
merchant location show the ID card the
merchant scan the barcode to verify that
the beneficiary has enough money on his
or her account on the application
merchant can select item by item and the
number of item and at the end of the
process the application made the total
automatically he sent all the
information to our server the server
validate the transaction and send a
message back to the merchant to confirm
that the transaction is okay
with our system the cost American
transact right now it was good and since
then we have developed other project
with digicel there has been a lot of
good improvement regarding ICT
especially after the earthquake there is
no way we'll be able to develop without
this
you